don't you dare this time on banded
Patrol little turkey fox fur is flying
when two orphan families learn to share
then oh you're kind of telling me an
American icon needs a helping hand and
an irritated mama duck
creates chaos in a parking lot
[Music]
the temperature is rising in Western
Kentucky you are beautiful and so is the
workload for wildlife rehabber Nikki
Christian I rehab all kinds of different
animals I never know what I'm going to
come across when I'm rescuing the animal
what were you doing
rehab work keeps her on the road quite a
bit
today Nikki and her daughter JC are at
home let's start out with this side
they're beginning a difficult process of
combining two families of orphaned foxes
she's recently taken in my plan is to
take these two smaller families and
actually merge them into one big family
larger Fox families actually do better
in the wild all right JC now it's time
for you to go hunting I think they're
all in that long before Nikki can merge
the family she must first begin a strict
vaccination protocol
s foxes are highly you know susceptible
to getting the December see it's good
stuff
it's a virus and it can spread through
the whole family it's highly contagious
for these boxes and I need to get them
vaccinated as soon as possible
surprisingly I don't just try to eat my
fingers off
he's like I don't like you but it tastes
alright last one
I'm sorry sweetheart
good job good job
with rehabbing it's not just about
feeding them every single day and then
releasing them I worry about these
little guys I want to make sure that
they know exactly what they need to do
out in the wild so I have all these
little steps that they have to cross
before I let them go
the first step it's time to eat assess
their hunting skills
guess what I got oh you smell it don't
you
Nikki starts with a family of foxes that
she affectionately calls the Dukes
I might give you plenty Dukes of Hazzard
was one of my favorite shows growing up
so it just kind of felt right to name
them Bo Luke Daisy and Cooter
the most important thing that I want to
see this morning is everybody being
aggressive taking control eating it or
hiding it
one of them just bit my foot so I'm
getting out
oh
Bo has been the aggressive one of them
Daisy's gonna star one that's staying
back there eating alone
the other two are trying to fight over
one mouth at a time
none of these guys have a problem with
aggression
all right you can't eat no more now
you're gonna hide dig and hide
Beau is taking the mice and he's
actually hiding them that's what he's
going to do in the wild so we can come
back later on and eat this is exactly
what I needed to see
still don't know how he's the rent
[Music]
show the behavior they'll need to do
well in the wild
now it's time to test the family next
door
the foxy bunch
[Music]
these guys are not near as aggressive as
the other set was I'm not liking what
I'm seeing right now because I want them
out and I want them fighting for their
food and they're not doing it all
releasing these animals without knowing
for sure they can find their own food
could be a death sentence
the next couple weeks are crucial these
guys have to prove to me that they're
ready to go out in the wild the mice
that I'll be putting in there next week
they're not going to just lay there
they're going to run they're going to
hide and they're going to have to chase
them they're not as aggressive but
they're eating
a few miles away it's dinner time as
well hey hungry
but fellow rehabber Nancy Reynolds isn't
having any problems getting her newest
patient to eat I
fall
something really cool is how you know
they're full can you see the milk line
see the difference
on the top and the bottom how wide it is
right there it's a little belly and it's
full of milk
is that good
[Music]
is it good
no baby I see you later caring for
Animals is a 24-hour a day job
so the calls don't stop even when the
Sun goes down
Honey about a fawn uh he's balancing hay
out in the field and he ran over the
baby hopefully he just nicked it but I'm
not expecting it to look good when I get
there
how are you pretty good you got a deer
for me
[Music]
I was cutting the hay in my field and
when I looked back there was a little
deer and uh one of which legs was gone
so I knew I had to do something with it
the leg is cut completely off
so I know there's lots of veins and
arteries I don't know why it's not
bleeding more but all the limbs are
really cold on it
the injury on this Fawn is more than I
can handle it's okay
so I'm calling my fellow rehab broker
Kristen Allen and she's going to meet me
at the house to pick it up
all the way at the shoulder
Kristen and her newly licensed daughter
Adrian assess the status of the Fawn
that Nancy has nicknamed Abby
I've never had a front leg injury like
Avi had I'm very hopeful that I can
rehabilitate this animal but right now I
just want to get them through the night
tomorrow morning first thing I'll take
him to Dr kunzi and just see what we can
do
you did an amazing job amazing
time is always an important factor when
you're dealing with any animal we just
wanted to get him in a situation that he
was going to be stable
you know what I'll be Adrian usually
tries to turn the air conditioner on
this is my excuse to turn the heater on
it was a miracle that saved this Fawn he
should have bled to death he is the
strongest fighter I have ever seen all
we can do is keep warm until we get home
that's my job yep
flush every bit of nastiness out of that
back home they waste no time tending to
the wound
I don't know
yes I did
it's really important to get this wound
as clean as we possibly can any bit of
dirt and bacteria can cause infection
that looks pretty good after we
irrigated all the grass out of it we
covered that wound really good with
chlorhexidine
chlorhexidine acts as an antiseptic it
should ward off infection until the
wound can be closed
I know handsome I know
[Music]
a fawn can be doing great and then they
can crash it's gonna be a long night
we're going to be up checking on him
just to make sure that he's doing well
the most difficult part of rehabbing is
deciding when to treat an animal and
when to be merciful
I've heard there are a lot of
three-legged deer out in the wild and
they thrive
the question is does he have the will to
live to get through this
there you go
nearby Nancy's night continues to
deliver surprises oh wow
now she responds to a call about a
raptor that a citizen rescuer noticed
was unable to fly he's humongous
he'd been down in a field and we had to
take him because he would not stand a
chance of survival on the ground
go straight from my arm aren't you
the first thing that I noticed about
this raptor is it is definitely a bald
eagle
they have very very powerful beaks
yep
feel your Keel buddy and he will bite
it's like a massive bite but what
concerns me about this bald eagle is I
could feel the Keel sticking out which
is basically the bone in the breast of
the bird that means they have not had
food in a long time
gotta go in the crate
Wings down buddy
you want his fish
goodness
Hey Big Boy
oh you were not happy in this little
crate
this is a very very cool and exciting
moment because this bird is huge it's
powerful and I have not ever seen them
up close like this
since this bald eagle is a federally
protected bird there's a lot of rules
and regulations that go along with these
animals I can have a bald eagle in my
care for 48 hours or less time to the
ride so I'm gonna take this Eagle Home
give it some food and water and first
thing in the morning I'm gonna take it
to a wildlife center that is licensed to
rehab Raptors you are heavy back home
Nancy has to transfer the eagle to a
bigger crate
hello big boy and this time around she
won't have any help my head in here with
an eagle
nope oh you're trying to tell on me
aren't you
those Talons are super sharp I mean they
would break the bones in my hands if
they got a hold of my hands
come out keep his wings down because I
don't want to hurt him
you are really mad
this Eagle is fighting me every chance
it gets I have to be careful so I don't
get hurt or it doesn't get hurt in the
process of moving it from one crate to
the other quit flapping
oh this isn't one of my favorite things
to do no
a bald eagle's razor sharp talons and
Powerful grip turn even a simple cage
transfer into a rush
foreign
this Eagle is so strong it feels like
it's going to take off with you holding
it
when he's down
this isn't one of my favorite things to
do but
foreign
because this is really cool but it was
really scary at the same time this is
the biggest bird that I have dealt with
and the most amazing bird definitely the
strongest
this is a juvenile bald eagle so as it
grows and gets a little older it matures
it will get that white head on it
he is mad
tomorrow it's off to a local Wildlife
Sanctuary for a full exam
but for now it's time for some rest
that was a workout
[Music]
closing you up buddy
Abby the Little Fawn with the missing
leg survives the critical first night it
was a miracle that saved this Fawn the
amount of arteries and veins in this
spawn's leg he should have bled to death
we're gonna go see Dr kunzi okay
but now we need to take him to the vet
and get that leg stitched up and he
needs to make it through the surgery
you ready
hello you know I always bring you the
unbelievable hey Baylor of course
I picked him up from Nancy was barely
bleeding he acts perfect other than only
having three legs it looks like there
ought to be adequate skin there to close
it okay the bigger question will be you
know long term how does he do can he get
around well after we do it well I think
let's get hair clipped away and flush it
out real well and then I'll just try and
close everything up
I'm incredibly nervous as Abby goes into
surgery this or Fawn has gone through so
much and now I'm having to put them
under anesthesia
you still doing good
foreign
[Music]
just kind of picked his little head up
and looked at us like hey guys you know
what's going on why are we all here
thanks Dr kunzi
going forward his balance there's a lot
of stress on the opposite leg so I do
worry how he's going to do with that
they're going to be the death of me all
these sweet little bonds this guy's a
fighter you look so good he is bound to
determine that he's going to live thanks
guys I appreciate it
[Music]
I love it boy are you ready
the juvenile bald eagle that Nancy calls
Freedom hi Nancy hey how are you
arrives at the Broadbent Wildlife
Sanctuary for a thorough exam I brought
you something very pretty today
veterinarian Dr Michael O'Brien and his
assistant Scott are on hand to answer
the question of why this Eagle is unable
to fly been on the ground for five days
just hopping around around the lake
[Music]
well it doesn't appear that he has any
broken wings
his range of motion is good there's no
bone grating on bone
take a look at his mouth and his eyes
here Scott
but we don't seem to have any parasites
in here
[Music]
Doc is giving this Eagle a good once
over but he has not finding anything
wrong
he gives it some fluids and treatment
for dehydration malnutrition and hope
that it gets better soon
sounds like a little baby though it does
it sounds like a baby bird
Freedom will be moved to an observation
cage where Dr O'Brien will try to
diagnose its condition
but first it'll have to be treated for
parasitic mites common in Birds we're
going to go right out the door
mites take nutrients away from the eagle
which will make it weaker so Doc's going
to have Scott hold the eagle while he
does it off it'll just kill the mites
but it won't harm the bird at all
just a real treat for us to get an
opportunity to put one of these birds
back into the beautiful picture of
Mother Nature Made Farm
over the next few days Dr O'Brien will
do blood work to determine the sex of
the bird and try to solve the mystery as
to why this Eagle can't fly
we'll do everything we can for him cool
thank you so much
[Music]
today Nikki and her daughter JC are up
early sit down for just a second
it's time for their two sets of orphaned
foxes to take on their next big
challenge
definitely not my kind of breakfast
the digs did great last time but using
live prey is a whole new ballgame as far
as the foxy Bunch when they see this
live prey I hope those Natural Instincts
kind of kick in I know they'll be ready
for the wild
I don't know if I can do this
because they're looking at me like that
proxies they're great for our
environment they keep all the Roman
population under control but it doesn't
make it any easier for me to put these
cute little mice in this enclosure
can you do it yeah are you sure yeah
but I'm just kind of right in the center
and then come on out
everything that they have eaten has been
non-moving today is the first time that
they're actually going to have to chase
and fight for their food so I'm kind of
anxious to see if everybody's going to
you know jump on board or not
fighting for the foxes in the other half
and rooting for the mice
both doing his thing as always
exactly what I expected these sets to do
they're fighting for it they are
searching everywhere for these ones it's
a good day for the foxes not for the
mice
these guys did absolutely perfect what
I'm worried about is these guys are here
so let's see how they do
once again you're up
next door it's time to put the foxy
bunch to the test
in that Natural Instinct and make them
go Hog Wild
stare at it
grab it
foxes and mice are natural adversaries
but it seems Nikki's little orphans
didn't get the memo
now the mouse is crawling away
it's crazy
this is very concerning to me right now
I expected him to not be as aggressive
but I didn't expect them to do
absolutely nothing if they can't find
their prey and hunt or even have the
desire to that's not good
the ones that have eight 20 mice are
trying to get through the fence to eat
more mice another ones are doing nothing
Nikki needs a plan to jump start the
fox's Natural Instincts grab it
we'll just stare at it without proof
they can find food on their own release
is out of the question
it's almost like a chicken Time Bomb I
have to get them ready for a winner and
the quicker that I get them out there
the quicker they find their food source
they find their place of shelter and
rest before winter kicks in
this is nuts
[Music]
don't be scared of the mouse
[Music]
all right Mr Avi you ready
obby's A Little Fawn defies the odds
you ready for a bottle only a week after
surgery he's back on his feet and ready
for more come on handsome
have it I don't have it come here come
here she's got it come here
look at you
get your exercise whoops get on the
carpet get on the carpet why don't you
take that one go to that end we'll make
him practice his walking
up to this point I was just concerned
about this animal surviving now I'm
concerned about him thriving seeing him
up on his three legs I'm just like I
think this guy could do it
here Robbie
[Music]
dude what's your what's your shoes
because I'm not left-handed
he's really got good balance I can't
believe that he's standing me either
[Music]
oh baby
he's like I can't I'm struggling turn
around there you go good job
I'm so proud of you because this is my
first Fawn that actually has a front leg
missing I'm gonna be exceptionally
careful with this guy we need to make
sure that he can balance well that he
can walk that he can run everything that
a regular four-legged deer can do Abby
has to be able to do it too
it's a good thing he likes his milk so
much because if he didn't he probably
wouldn't think it was worth all this
work exactly
oh mom's got more mom's got more
happy come on let's go
good job
[Music]
he goes I can't finish two bottles
I'm done thanks Mom
balancing on three legs is just the
first step next week he'll have to prove
he can run and jump outside on some less
forgiving terrain here he left a little
bit
he didn't want to be a pig
[Music]
back at the wildlife sanctuary Nancy
checks up on her favorite new patient
and she arrives to some exciting news
[Music]
doc did some DNA tests to figure out
that the ginger of this Eagle is a
female so I'm so excited because she's
gonna get to lay eggs one day and make
more babies just excited
foreign 's looking a lot better but it's
not really flying yet so I hope the doc
has some more information as to why it's
still not flying
you got some X-rays of wings did we find
anything
looks really good as far as skeletal
structure as long as we're clear
so was it just weak
no she has a contusion or a bruise in
her left shoulder where she had flown
into something and luckily didn't
fracture a wing
Freedom's bruised shoulder is likely why
she can't fly
a little more rest and care and she
should start taking short flights soon
that will begin her real Rehabilitation
process that's when she can start really
practicing and building muscle and I
think that could take two or three
months I have total confidence that she
is going to fly
cool I'm excited
[Music]
so I'll be back in a few weeks to see
how Freedom shoulder is feeling if its
shoulder is better then we'll be able to
put it through some flight tests to see
how it's really doing
Kristen's daughter Adrian now a licensed
rehabber herself rushes to deal with a
crisis at a local shopping center mom
called me to see about a situation in a
parking lot with some baby ducklings and
a mama duck
it's right in here Sofia
Kristen is on the way but the situation
is too dangerous for Adrian and her
younger sister Sophia to wait so mom's
on the move
what is it
[Music]
push it over there
[Music]
my mom flew away and she's flying all
over the parking lot so Sophia's with
her and I'm gonna go ahead and try to
get the babies
we're gonna go to a plan B and try to
catch the babies first and see if the
mama will come back to them
[Music]
okay I got all 12 babies we aren't
really sure why this mama duck chose to
raise her babies in a parking lot I
guess she saw the really nice Bush and
decided that that was a safe place but
she was wrong
hey Mama it's okay
come on
she's gonna get hit
it's parking lot pandemonium
as Wildlife rehabber Adrian Allen and
her sister Sophia try to Wrangle a duck
leading them on a wild goose chase
mama duck come on we're trying to help
you
Sophia and I are having a really
difficult time catching this mama duck
because she just continues to Circle and
fly all over the place so Mom comes into
the rescue and she's got a new idea
so guys borrow this from the pet store
down here I put the crate inside of it
we're just gonna let her go in and we're
just gonna bide our time something you
will learn as you get old patience is a
virtue
foreign
chasing a mother dog around the parking
lot is not safe for the mama duck or the
people chasing her so now that I've come
up with a plan I really think that mom's
gonna go into that crate and we can get
this mama and her ducklings back in the
country where they belong
okay just stay there we're blocking
traffic right here so this is okay
success
it wasn't definitely a true test of
patience I'm like you have to be patient
when you're doing these things you got
to bide your time
you gotta go somewhere to say I'll get
you some water I love you guys love you
a parking lot is no place to raise your
babies so Adrian and Sophia bring the
Ducks to a nearby location that will be
perfect for this growing family
this will be a much safer place for them
than that parking lot you ready Mama
duck was not happy that we were trying
to relocate her but moving her to a new
place her babies are going to be safe
and I know that she'll be a lot happier
come on babies I'm gonna grab something
go find her go find her
is that 12. one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve and a
mom
look at them
they're gonna love a happy little safe
life here
[Music]
Nikki and fox families the Dukes and the
foxy Bunch are in a Race Against Time
we're gonna open this middle part the
foxes will have a better chance of
survival in the wild if they're released
together but one of the families isn't
hearing the call to hunt if they don't
start kicking it up a notch and letting
me see that natural instinct
you're gonna be staying with me for the
winter I'm gonna walk you in there
let me go the other side
Nikki has one last trick up her sleeve
and she's hoping it'll put the foxy
Bunch on the path to release
foxes learn behavior from other foxes I
want to combine these two families a
little bit sooner than I even planned
just because I'm hoping that this more
aggressive group can show these other
ones how to do it the right way
it's a technique she's used before but
it does involve some risk
okay we'll do your thing
on one hand they might get in there and
just love each other and be perfectly
fine but these guys are big enough that
if they wanted to fight they're going to
hurt each other
[Music]
there you go
no I was nervous but they're doing great
my last little step is to put mice back
in here and see how the whole family
does and make sure that the ones that
wouldn't be in aggressive can step up to
the plate
and a half and half or what yeah I'll do
half and half
all right come on out
there you go
I'm hoping this plan works live prey
kind of kicks in that natural instinct
oh he got one yes
that's awesome
[Music]
this makes me feel a lot better
[Music]
I have seen exactly what I needed to see
the Dukes are doing great but when the
foxy bites kind of jumped in it kind of
got everybody going
these guys get caught up
they are all
doing great
I'll sleep easy tonight just because
these guys did everything I needed them
to do they were pouncing they're eating
they're fighting for their food
cups
they're ready for the wild I'm gonna
give them a little bit more time just to
fatten up but they're ready this is kind
of like their graduation day
it says awesome
Sophia will you help me take all these
stitches out it's been almost three
weeks since I'll be the Fawn arrived at
Kristen's home with a wound that nearly
cost him his life
the emergency operation to save him was
a success and it's time to see how he's
healing kind of unthreads from there
I know handsome I'm sorry the leg was
looking good the stitches were ready to
come out
[Music]
you're fine this Fawn is truly a little
miracle
um it's amazing that he lived having the
leg cut off
[Music]
here we go we done nope yeah don't let
him go yet all right I got it the plan
is to move Abby to a large outdoor pen
with their other fawns but first they
need to see how he navigates uneven
terrain with only three legs all right
buddy
let's go out here and get some exercise
we just want to make sure that he gets
around well because he has to be able to
run like the other deer
I know this is all new
well he says oh grass
it's my hobby
there you go oh little turkey when Avi
takes off like a shot my heart sank
letting Avi go at this stage of his life
is like sending a baby out in the woods
and saying hey see how you can do
don't you dare
all right
come on Abby
there you go oh little turkey Harvey the
injured Fawn is taking his first steps
back into the Great Outdoors
and the fact that he's down a leg
doesn't seem to slow him down one bit
there you go okay fenced area for you
there you go you did great I'm so proud
we're going down to the fenced area
Abby proved to me today that my golly he
can run just like the other ones this is
awesome I'm like except you scared the
pajeebers out of me
the good part of it was is man he was
jumping over those branches like he had
four legs
all right quit throwing your fit dude
it's been a long time since you smelled
these smells and heard these sounds
hasn't it
so you didn't follow Sophia around is is
amazing it's really amazing
when I got Abby in he had no front leg
at all because the hay baler took it off
it was a miracle he didn't lead to death
and I didn't know if he was ever going
to even live let alone if he would be
able to run out in the wild again to see
him out here is just unbelievable like
it's this is awesome
obviously stop crying I know
seriously it's not that hard I'm awesome
let's take him to the barn I think he's
ready
[Music]
let's go
Bobby's remaining time will be spent at
a nearby Barn where he'll take his place
among the other fawns that the Allens
have taken in this season
[Music]
come on handsome
[Music]
oh yeah she says hello friend hello oh
your tail moves
fawns and deer are very social animals
they live in herds and so this is
important for him to know what he is and
know that this is what's going to keep
him safe when he's released
if all goes well in a few short months
Avi should be ready for release with all
the other fawns
I'm with your new friends
see you in a little while
[Music]
Nancy is back at the wildlife sanctuary
to check in on freedom the juvenile bald
eagle see what's going on with freedom
and her boyfriend today she's now in an
outdoor enclosure with a full-grown male
and it seems the two are hitting it off
okay
when we first put them together
[Music]
he didn't like her too good
but after he figured out that she was
young and single and uh
they now want to be close to each other
there she goes ah there I think I love
you this is so sweet to watch these two
definitely have some kind of chemistry
it's been a good thing for both Eagles
to have them together
and hopefully we can release them as a
pair that's what I would like to do with
a steady diet and plenty of care Freedom
shows signs that her bruised shoulder is
healing
I'm really amazed at how far she's come
by the way she looked and how weak she
was and just thin and now seeing the way
she looks it's it's amazing
step back in that corner okay and I'm
going to walk down there and see if
she'll fly from perch to perch
it's time to assess her Wing strength
with a flight test a critical Milestone
before her release
I have never seen her fly and I'm really
excited to see her at least use those
wings just a little bit
you ready
[Music]
there's a series of tests that they're
going to go through to see her flight
and this one was a distance of 60 feet
[Music]
I think we're making her nervous
ah beautiful
oh sorry come back
she made it before we go awesome first
time and she's uh went from purse to
perch that one good that's really
exciting
I asked the first test going from perch
to perch she flew So Graceful it was
beautiful to watch her do that
we're really in a state of success at
this point I really believe both of them
will get to fly
the next steps for this Eagle is a
little more practice in this flight cage
because the more she flies she's going
to strengthen up those wings the more
confident she'll get and the quicker
she'll be able to be released
it was fun they look great I really look
forward to seeing it released and flying
and being free
[Music]
today Nancy joins Nikki to say farewell
to Nikki's Posse of orphaned foxes
they've got Creek that runs right there
and then there's no telling how many
mice bunnies Quail everything else is
out here for them so it's a perfect food
source yeah they're gonna love it
Nikki and Nancy dug a makeshift burrow
for The Foxes to use as shelter and to
be sure they see it they'll funnel them
directly into the entrance
if you just release them they're going
to take off running I don't want these
foxes to do that I want them to know
that this place is a safe place for them
time to go come on
[Music]
with the last of the foxes in the den
one by one they venture out to explore
their new surroundings
head out
oh they all seem really happy
[Music]
so curious and playful
these guys are having an absolute blast
they are playing they're kind of
pouncing on each other and running back
in seeing them running back to their
safe place is the best thing I could
have seen today oh they love it yeah
this is Paradise for a fox my favorite
part was watching them run and then they
was hopping through the weeds like
little rabbits it was just hilarious
this is the day that I feel blessed the
fact that I could sit there and watch
them play like that is it was absolutely
magical these guys are not going to just
live they're going to thrive
[Music]
they're absolutely loving this area
[Music]
hi guys how are you
it's a big day for Avi the three-legged
Fawn and the rest of the deer that the
Allen Family rescued this season are you
ready for your field trip today
today is a super exciting day we're
going to move the fawns from the barn to
Broadbent Wildlife Sanctuary where
they're going to be released
try whatever's going to work getting
them in the trailer
each of these animals has a special
story to tell about courage and survival
but none quite like Hobbies
who would have thought that a deer that
got his leg cut off by a hay baler would
actually even survive let alone be
released back out in the wild again this
is like amazing this is why I do this
come on
come on let's go who wants the bottles
all the leader
come on guys come on everybody out the
place where you're going is big and
beautiful I feel like I'm doing a deer
dance here over here trying to keep them
from getting through me even though they
trust us and we've raised them they're
apprehensive we're putting them in
something that they've never been in
before so just gonna have to pick them
up and put them in there
[Applause]
with the last of the passengers loaded
up let's go let's go it's off to the
sanctuary for the final stage of their
rehab
[Music]
oh my gosh Come on
good job Bobby
this is awesome isn't it Abby and his
friends will spend a couple weeks in
this large enclosure before being
allowed to take full advantage of the
sanctuary
are really going through like kind of a
soft release they have to build up a
little stamina it's kind of like
somebody that's training for a marathon
you don't just go run the marathon you
take small little steps
have you ever seen any place this big
before
they are so excited they're like running
and jumping they're going Abby go on
me I got this man I got this
three legs yes
every fall you get you're attached to
but like Avi if you don't count legs you
don't know which one is him
Avi you're awesome
all right guys I think we need to say
our goodbyes
I'll be
the Big World out here dude
I know you're gonna have to build some
endurance out here aren't you
love you
[Music]
Avi is gonna do amazing here nobody's
gonna tell him out in the wild that
handles only has three legs I'm so proud
of him
it's my last kiss
[Music]
[Music]